se desplazan en tren en autobús en ferry
e incluso caminando los ucranianos usan
cualquier medio disponible para dejar
atrás la guerra que se extiende por su
país así luce uno de los refugios de la
ciudad de dumbrava beni que acoge a unos
2.000 refugiados
katrina tuvo que huir y narra como vio
su recorrido
cuando estábamos parados en la frontera
había un padre con tres hijos tres niños
y el más pequeño estaba muy cansado
porque ya llevábamos más de cinco horas
esperando en las filas para cruzar la
frontera
[Música]
y empezó a decir papá volvamos a casa el
padre le dijo perdón hijo ya no tenemos
casa nuestra casa fue bombardeada
tenemos que seguir adelante tenemos que
hacer una nueva vida hay que ser fuertes
su visión más allá de las fronteras
ucranianas los millones de refugiados
deben reescribir sus vidas desde cero
para el caso de estas violinistas
ucranianas su nueva vida comienza con
sus instrumentos
huyeron de harkov al este del territorio
ucraniano cuando comenzaron los
bombardeos
ahora se refugian en la escuela
escandinava de violoncello que desde que
comenzó la guerra abrió sus puertas a
músicos ucranianos
todos nuestros instrumentos están a
salud gracias a dios
no son las botas nuestra ropa no son las
joyas es sólo nuestro talento y nuestro
instrumento
la situación sigue siendo crítica en
ucrania donde según acnur ya hay al
menos 185 millones de desplazados
internos y unas 12 85 millones de
personas se han visto directamente
afectadas por el conflicto